[Music]
if i can ask for a gift for the american
people from president resign let
everybody just get along
and we get rid of this covet stuff
we were going pretty good there until he
showed up and
all the things he signed and got rid of
it's just a joke
you know that i'd probably ask him to
wake up
try to get the senate to work together
somehow
good luck but yeah that's it
[Music]
you asked the wrong person there yeah i
don't know i want him to make this
america great again and i am totally a
trump person but
you know i go along with anything as
long as we can get something straight
and
they need to put up the border wall and
finish it
i ditto
[Music]
you know i think they're doing
an okay job no i think they're doing an
okay job
given what they started out with
[Music]
no
i disagree
you know the second that he said open
the borders just like are you that dumb
my thoughts on the borders why did we
quit building a wall
that's the biggest one i can think of
right there because uh it worked
i guess it will work eventually and in
the end
i think uh
it hasn't been that bad here that i've
seen i've heard about it
and they say a lot of them are here but
i've been pretty nice where i'm at
you